whether these actors left fans behind
during the franchise or after it had
concluded these losses still left harry
potter fans
devastated from potions masters to
ministry officials to magical creatures
here's a list of harry potter cast
members you may not know passed away
as soon as harry potter arrives at his
new home at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry he meets his
professors
immediately clashing with the school's
potions master severus snape
throughout the series snape unfairly
antagonizes harry and his friends
deducting points over small mistakes and
squabbles and favoring students from
slytherin house
mr potter
our new celebrity
the pair's animosity only gets worse
when snape is forced to try to teach
harry the art of occlumency which could
help harry block his mind against
voldemort
he'll listen to that
however as it turns out snape was
helping harry all along as a childhood
friend of harry's mother lily
snape was always in love with her and he
pretended to serve voldemort while
reporting to dumbledore
risking his life as a double agent alan
rickman was
the perfect choice to play the enigmatic
snape who turns out to be one of the
series most
complex characters rickman brought this
character to life becoming a beloved
figure to millions of potter fans
in 2016 rickman lost his life to
pancreatic cancer
and fans fellow actors and co-stars
alike
paid their tributes to rickman the role
of albus dumbledore
harry's wisened caring mentor throughout
the series required an
actor with enough gravitas and heart to
bring this part to life
and for the first two harry potter films
richard harris played the character to
absolute perfection a gentle giant whose
kindness
is never diminished by his incredible
power dumbledore serves as harry's
makeshift father figure and personal
teacher
sharing his boundless wisdom with harry
as he gets older
however when dumbledore dies at the end
of the sixth installment
harry potter and the half-blood prince
harry must go it alone
armed only with the lessons dumbledore
taught him along the way
as he sets out to defeat voldemort
dumbledore doesn't lose his life until
the sixth film
but unfortunately audiences lost the
first dumbledore
after only the second installment after
making two potter films harris was
diagnosed with hodgkin's disease in 2002
and after he was hospitalized with
pneumonia he died in a london hospital
michael gambin moved forward with the
role of dumbledore but harris's legacy
lives on through his sons
one of whom is the acclaimed actor jared
harris who has appeared in shows like
madmen
and chernobyl harry potter faces
plenty of hardship throughout his life
and in his pre-hogwarts years
most of that turmoil is caused by the
dursleys a trio of extended family
members with whom harry spent an
incredibly
unhappy childhood after his parents are
killed by voldemort
harry must live with his mother's sister
petunia her awful husband vernon
and their dreadful son dudley all of
whom hate harry for his magical ability
and make his life as
miserable as possible despite the fact
that harry and the dursleys hate each
other equally
harry must return to their house every
summer when hogwarts is on break
making them important characters in the
story any
funny business any at all
and you won't have any meals for a week
as such when it came time to cast the
dursleys producer saw fit to cast fiona
shaw and richard griffiths
two titans of the british stage and
screen as petunia and vernon
respectively
in addition to working on the potter
films griffiths teamed up with daniel
radcliffe to appear on stage in equus
from 2007 to 2009 on both london's west
end
and broadway but unfortunately their
working relationship was cut
too short far too soon griffiths lost
his life to complications from heart
surgery in 2013
after losing his friend and co-star
radcliffe led a touching tribute to the
legendary actor saying he was quote
proud to say he knew him plenty of
legendary actors appeared in the harry
potter film series and
few were more well renowned than john
hurt as harry goes shopping in diagon
alley he meets the mysterious enigmatic
olivander
the man who provides wands to the entire
magical community
and tells him an important secret about
his own wand
i wondered when i'd be seeing you mr
potter
thanks to a magical bond between harry
and voldemort the wand that has chosen
the young wizard shares a core with
voldemort's creating a lifelong
connection
later ollivander must help harry uncover
the secrets of the elder wand in order
to stop voldemort once and for all
hurt played olivander in a handful of
potter films including the first
and last but you might also recognize
this stalwart actor from v for vendetta
and indiana jones as well as a short
stint as the war doctor on doctor who
and more hurt became a knight of the
order of the british empire in 2015
for his services to drama but sadly he
passed away only a few years later in
2017 from complications from pancreatic
cancer
after harry is officially introduced to
the magical world by rubius hagrid
his first official entry into wizardry
is when hagrid takes him to diagon alley
the magical street where witches and
wizards can buy all of the supplies they
need for spells
potion making and more in an otherwise
non-descript mughal street in london
harry discovers the leaky cauldron a pub
that seems to go totally unnoticed by
any non-magical folk and in the backyard
wizards can gain entry into diagon
alley by tapping a specific combination
of bricks on the wall
as the bartender of the leaky cauldron
tom is an important background character
bless my soul it's harry potter
tom only appeared briefly in the film
series but in the first film he was
played by british actor derek deadman
throughout his career dedmond appeared
in a variety of high-profile projects
including a streetcar named desiree in
1991.
deadman passed away in 2014 at the age
of 74 from complications from diabetes
leaving the leaky cauldron permanently
unmanned
of course the world of harry potter
isn't all heroes voldemort has plenty of
bad guys under his thumb
one of whom is the dangerous werewolf
fenrir greyback
a ruthless and hungry monster greyback
bites for fun to create a new army of
werewolves
during half-blood prince greyback
attacks the eldest weasley son
bill dealing a devastating blow to harry
and his loved ones
but he's ultimately taken down by the
good guys greyback required a
particularly imposing actor and dave
lageno was up to the task
a trained mixed martial artist
proficient in everything from muay thai
to judo to boxing to brazilian jiu jitsu
lageno passed away in 2014 during a hike
in death valley
reportedly from problems caused by the
extreme heat
in the franchise's fourth installment
harry potter and the goblet of fire
harry finds himself faced with an
entirely new challenge
after his name is somehow placed in the
champion choosing goblet of fire for a
multi-school
tri-wizard tournament harry must compete
much to everyone chagrin
throughout the tournament he encounters
barty crouch senior a strict
high-ranking ministry director
overseeing the operations of the
tournament
however what harry learns later about
crouch is that he has a tragic past
his son barty crouch jr played by david
tennant was previously arrested with a
group of death eaters
and he has returned with voldemort's
help to exact revenge upon his father
since barty crouch senior is such an
established member of the ministry it
stands to reason that a venerated actor
like roger lloyd pack would be the one
to play him
pack worked extensively on british
television before he passed away from
pancreatic cancer
in 2014 when it comes to magical
creatures in the harry potter
universe few are more mysterious than
house elves
this subservient species tends to attach
itself to a certain family performing
cooking
cleaning whatever their master asks
however harry ends up with much more
than he bargained for when he ends up
owning creature
a surly house elf who once belonged to
his late godfather sirius black
after sirius's death harry inherited
ownership of preacher but it took
creature time to warm to him
visually creature was an entirely
computer-generated character
but he was voiced by timothy bateson an
established british voice actor
voicing creature in the fifth movie
order of the phoenix was bateson's last
role before he passed away in 2009
for the rest of the series creature was
voiced by simon mcburney
as harry enters diagon alley for the
first time one of his first stops is
gringotts
the vast wizarding bank that holds some
of the magical world's most closely held
treasures and secrets
just to add to its mystique gringotts is
guarded by goblins which are easily the
most
secretive and cryptic magical creatures
in harry's world and one of the first
goblins harry meets is griphook
who leads him down into gringotts dark
and well-guarded vaults
though griphook returns in later films
he's played by a different actor as the
series continues
in the first movie vern troyer portrays
the prominent goblin
[Music]
and does mr harry potter have his key
troyer has a fairly extensive film and
television
resume but most people likely know him
best as mini-me to mike myers dr evil in
the austin powers franchise
tragically troyer passed away in 2018
his death was later ruled to suicide
however his performances in everything
from harry potter to austin powers will
live on
forever when harry arrives at hogwarts
the magic within the school astounds him
food appears on tables as if by magic he
can wave a wand and make anything happen
the staircases change frequently and in
an unnerving twist the paintings on the
walls move and talk
one of those paintings the fat lady is
in charge of guarding the entrance to
gryffindor tower
and in the films she was played by
british actress elizabeth spricks
a shakespearean actress spriggs only
made an appearance in the first film
before her untimely death in 2008.
dawn french replaced sprigs as the fat
lady popping up in 2004's harry potter
and the prisoner of azkaban
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one